Hm
probability of a collapse is proportional to the number of events or curry.
And so the more events occur,
the more likely extremely unlikely events are to take place.
And everything's been speeding up,
really speeding up.
I mean,
you think about how many trades now are made in microseconds by computer,
you know,
so my suspicions are if you calculated the complexity of the trading system and
held that constant that the rate of failure would be about the same.
It seems to be highly problem.
In fact,
it would really surprise me if that wasn't the case because that's basically how
systems work.
You know,
there's a certain number of events that are outliers per certain number of
events.
So if you raise the number of events,
you raise that number of outliers.
And so I,
and you see this,
I think also reflected in things like tech company growth in collapse.
You know,
20 years ago,
the average lifespan of a company,
it was,
you know,
perhaps something around 30 to 40 years.
My suspicions are now that on average,
especially in fast changing fields,
that they don't last that long.
So you know,
we're speeding,
you know,
if you think time is actually a measure of the events,
average number of events,
well,
times events are occurring a lot faster now.
So time in some senses sped up,
at least in certain systems.